Одне з омріяних бажань Варшави -
мінімізувати або навіть взагалі звести до нуля поставки газу з Росії.
Вирішити це завдання покликаний газогін Baltic Pipe.
Планується, що цим трубопроводом газ постачатимуть
із Північного моря до Польщі і далі - до країн Балтії.
Простягнеться він від Норвезького шельфу через Данію
до польського узбережжя.
Пропускна потужність Baltic Рipe
складе 10 млрд кубометрів на рік.
Приблизно стільки ж газу Польща імпортує щорічно з Росії.
Ми не сумніваємося, що це не просто
польсько-норвезько-данський проект.
Це важливий проект для енергетичного сектора Європи,
для енергетичної незалежності Європейського Союзу.
Цей проект стосується майбутнього нашої частини Європи і нашої частини світу.
Завершити будівництво Baltic Рipe планують до 2022 року,
адже саме 31 грудня 22-го у Варшави закінчується
довгостроковий договір про імпорт російського газу.
Продовжувати його Польща не має наміру.
Часто можна почути, що Польща прокладає балтійську трубу
для того, щоб знизити свою залежність від поставок російського газу.
Це неправильно.
Варшава реалізує цей проект для того, щоб
повністю позбутися необхідності закуповувати газпромівську продукцію.
Завершення проекту заплановано на 1 жовтня 2022 року. Чому?
Щоб мати можливість протягом трьох місяців
вивести новеньку трубу на проектну потужність
і вже до 1 січня 2023 року припинити купувати газ у Росії.
Австрійський експерт із питань Східної Європи переконаний,
що справа тут не лише в комерції, але й у політиці.
Це, звісно, сигнал. Адже Польща не хоче
продовжувати ділові відносини з "Газпромом" саме з політичних міркувань,
і замість цього готова радше купувати газ із Норвегії
через газогін Baltic Pipe або зріджений газ із США.
Це чітка політична мета, яку переслідує Польща,
це чіткий політичний меседж. І це має
непокоїти Росію більше, аніж втрата фінансових надходжень
після припинення дії договору з Польщею.
У результаті російський концерн "Газпром"
вже менше ніж через 2 роки втратить доволі великий ринок збуту.
Польща - не просто один із найстаріших покупців газу з Росії,
не просто країна, з якою "Газпром" пов'язаний 30-річним контрактом.
Польща всі останні роки була найбільшим клієнтом "Газпрому" в Східній Європі,
входила в десятку найважливіших експортних ринків "Газпрому"
і у 2019 році закупила, наприклад, практично стільки ж,
скільки такий важливий західний європейський партнер, як Великобританія.
Загалом Польщі необхідно близько 18 мільярдів кубометрів газу на рік.
10 мільярдів поляки отримуватимуть через Baltic Pipe.
Решта - до речі, це ще одна альтернатива російському газу, -
це зріджений природний газ, насамперед зі США й Катару.
Хоча, не виключають експерти, це може бути
навіть зріджений газ від партнера,
від якого Польща хоче відмовитися.
Якщо він буде дешевшим, то чому б не купити його в Росії,
тим паче, що траса проходить через польську територію.
Цілком можна собі уявити комерційну домовленість,
не обтяжену політичними обставинами.
Тобто якийсь трейдер купив російський природний зріджений газ -
або в Балтійському морі, або його привезли з Ямальського півострова,
оскільки поки цей газ перебуває в розпорядженні трейдера,
то його політичне походження вже абсолютно нікого не хвилює, це вже інша власність.
У польському Свіноуйсьце на кордоні з Німеччиною
в районі Балтійського моря вже є термінал
для прийому зрідженого газу. Його потужність
збільшать із 5 до 7 з половиною мільярдів кубометрів.
Також у планах Варшави - будівництво плавучого ЗПГ-терміналу в Гданській протоці.
Тим часом побільшало проблем у "Газпрома" і з іншою трубою -
"Північним потоком-2", будівництво якого заморожене через американські санкції.
Минулого тижня німецький регулятор Федеральне агентство з мереж оголосило,
що "Газпром" не може розраховувати на особливі умови та,
згідно з німецьким законодавством, не може
одночасно володіти трубою і постачати по ній газ.
Апеляцію компанії Nord Stream 2 німецький регулятор відхилив,
і виняток з газової директиви ЄС для цієї труби не робитимуть.
Якщо "Північний потік -2" таки добудують, "Газпрому" доведеться
вирішувати питання відповідності цієї труби газовій директиві ЄС.
Тепер перед "Газпромом" клопітне, неприємне завдання,
але його можна вирішити: продати весь газопровід
або хоча б його кінцеву ділянку якійсь формально незалежній компанії.
Досвід німецької дочки "Газпрому" "Вінгаз" показує, що
така схема можлива, що можна розділити активи,
але при цьому зберегти контроль над ними.
Утім, експерти припускають більш серйозні наслідки
рішення Федерального агентства з мереж.
Росії доведеться змінювати свій підхід
до газового ринку взагалі, тобто скасовувати монополію "Газпрому" на експорт.
Тим часом "Академік Черський" - судно, яке
може спробувати добудувати газопровід замість ітлаійців та швейцарців,
які вийшли з проекту після санкцій США,
вже знаходиться в німецьких територіальних водах.
Рішення німців не означає, що проект помер і що
"Північний потік -2" не може бути добудований.
Будівельні роботи можуть тривати, якщо російська сторона
має для цього можливості. Навряд чи газопровід
просто облишать, але й без подальших затримок не обійдеться.
Із моменту запровадження санкцій США півроку тому
проект "Північний потік -2" не просунувся далі.
Будівництво готове на 94%.
Добудувати залишилося близько 150 кілометрів трубопроводу.